it took Alexander and his friends 24
hours to get into Georgia most of it was
spent waiting in a car eventually they
rented some bicycles a piece of luck he
says otherwise they might still be on
the other side he's clear why he's left
his homeland uh everybody knows the
situation really because
the politics is is wrong on my opinion
and you don't want to fight in the war
in Ukraine no of course I don't want to
kill
nice people
most of the people Al Jazeera spoke to
feel the same way about Russia's war in
Ukraine and while they are certain of
that uncertainty awaits them Igor is a
military-aged male eligible to be called
up in Russia's partial mobilization he
crossed the border on foot
my wife is waiting to cross the border
with her car we don't don't know what
times they will cross the border for for
the men part of the society so it is
just like a lottery game you know so you
never know you win or lose so my wife
told me two days I I go just go I will
follow you the shutting of borders has
become a concern
one of the few routes out of Russia via
Finland has now been closed by The
Finnish government and that's likely to
mean more people arriving here this
border crossing has become a political
Hot Potato what the government says is
before the announcement of partial
mobilization by the Russians there are
about 5 000 cars crossing a day that
figure has gone up to 11 000 but
opposition politicians are saying that
that's nowhere near an accurate figure
that the the actual number is far larger
than that but for the Russians who are
coming across they are allowed to stay
in the country for a year but
uncertainty actually awaits them they
don't know how long they can afford it
to actually stay here and more
importantly what awaits them when they
do eventually get back to Russia Imran
Khan Al Jazeera the Lassie border
crossing